[Music]
I'm Keith Olbermann and this is the
resistance this is a plea from what's
left of the United States of America to
the rest of the free world specifically
to the news media of the rest of the
free world please what happened in
Berlin to Ivanka Trump has to happen
everywhere any of the Trump's or the
Secretary of the State or the Vice
President or anybody else connected to
this misbegotten evil man stops long
enough to take questions our media has
been all but frozen out replaced by
propaganda outlets where nothing no
matter how outlandish or unamerican not
even a tax on the very freedom of speech
under which they operate get a follow up
question on those few occasions where
there is an opportunity to state that
Donald Trump is an existential threat to
the US and the free world our media has
largely choked it asks him questions
designed not to be challenging to his
fact-free worldview but designed to be
played on TV or itself censors overcome
at the crucial moment by desperate
stupid and ultimately pointless attempts
to as a source at one cable outfit
reportedly put it quote focus on Trump
voters last Saturday Trump compared
immigrants to snakes he called the rules
of the Senate and the house archaic his
chief of staff would on a Sunday morning
muse about a constitutional attack on
the First Amendment he invited the
murderous strongman of the Philippines
to the White House he complimented Kim
jong-un
he held a rally seemingly attended by
white nationalists and after all that
this was the headline in the sunday
Philadelphia Inquirer right under winner
of 20 Pulitzer Prizes quote touting
progress touting progress touting
fascism we hear the liberal media
Trump's fake news we pretend this is
just another presidency and just another
difference of political opinion even the
New York Times as Robert Duvall called
it in the movie Network the holy goddamn
New York Times the same morning remaking
the presidency Trump has
to expanding power and shunning norms
yet adapting to realities after 100 days
the hell he has adapting to what
realities as that newspaper hit the
streets his spokesman was talking about
a constitutional libel amendment so that
as Trump put it 11 months before his
inauguration we consumed the New York
Times and win lots of money in
interviews preceding his 100th day in
office
Trump showed a succession of reporters
the county-by-county map of his election
five months after the election and at
least half seriously suggested to a
reporter from The Washington Post that
the paper should print that map now on
its front page and instead of an article
asking how crazy anybody who would do
such a thing would have to be this
became an anecdote for the Washington
Post reporter to joke about much later
on television Trump told a Washington
Examiner reporter about his admiration
for Andrew Jackson and how Jackson was
really angry that he saw what was
happening with regard to the Civil War
he said there's no reason for this
Jackson left the presidency 24 years
before the Civil War started and in fact
had nearly precipitated a civil war 29
years before it started and he was a
slave owner Trump couldn't have been
more wrong about him if he had claimed
Andrew Jackson rode to his inauguration
in an automobile and yet the American
news media continues to treat Donald
Trump is just another story as the wacky
neighbor who just happens to have all
the nukes and it continues to treat the
Trump presidential families syndicate as
just another collection of white house
relatives so again my plea to the
journalists of the world do what Miriam
mekel the editor-in-chief of a German
business magazine did you're the first
daughter of the United States began Ms
mekel as she moderated a business panel
featuring Ivanka Trump the German
audience is not that familiar with the
concept of a first daughter I'd like to
ask you what is your role and whom are
you representing your father is
President of the United States the
American people or your business mr.
Trump who's
infused beauty pageant contestant grades
stupidity has largely been hidden from
the American audience stumbled through
her answer incredibly she then began to
laud her father's treatment of women I'm
very proud of my father's advocacy he's
been a tremendous champion of supporting
families and enabling them to thrive the
crowd then began to hiss boo and make
other verbal equivalents of eye rolling
you hear the reaction from the audience
the moderator mekel observed I need to
address one more point some attitudes
towards women
your father has publicly displayed in
former times might leave one questioning
whether he's such an empowered women
since Trump's election no one in this
country has asked a question that
pointed or that realistic or that
challenging of Trump or his spawn or his
key appointees and Miriam eckle asked
two of them I've certainly heard the
criticism from the media Ivanka Trump
replied again startled by reality and
sounding surprisingly like her father
all of a sudden that's been perpetuated
Miriam mekel deserves all the Pulitzer
Prizes the Murrow awards the Cronkite
awards the Emmys the Peabody's and any
other trophy we can hand her and she and
other reporters and editors and just
other citizens in Germany or England or
France or from those foreign
correspondents who are reporting from
the United States for the BBC or Oshkosh
prom press or the aardvark daily of
Wellington New Zealand or anybody who is
anywhere that members of this family or
this government might not be able to
elude the media you need to keep asking
pointed doubtful sceptical snarky
questions that our reporters are too
afraid to ask ask Trump if he's ever had
a cat-scan
ask Trump if he is experiencing
headaches or blurred vision or
hallucinations ask Rex Tillerson if he's
worried at all that evidence apparently
connecting his boss's campaign to
Russian electoral hacking continues to
mount
while his boss has resumed blaming China
for it asked the UN ambassador nikki
Haley if it's a problem at all that
Trump invited Duterte to the White House
and congratulate adair21 on destroying
democracy in Turkey
ask any of the Trump children why their
father has simultaneously enraged North
Korea and South Korea and China asked
them about the carl vinson armada bluff
and asked them about the conflation of
Kim jong-un and Kim Jong Il and asked
them about the white house education
story on snapchat that misspelled the
word education and asked them about how
the first lady seemingly had to
physically nudge Trump to put his hand
over his heart during the national
anthem or or just take anything from
that crazy Associated Press interview
where he said off the record that he
watched CNN and then said on the record
two minutes later but he never watched
CNN and asked him about it or that crazy
Reuters interview where he admitted he
thought life as president would be
easier than being a 70 year old conman
who inherited his money from his daddy
ask him or take the crazy rally in
Pennsylvania where he compared
immigrants to snakes when his own
grandparents were immigrants and his
mother was an immigrant and two of his
three wives have been immigrants and
four of his five kids are the children
of an immigrant and asked him ask him
for God's sake I'm begging you ask him
because the media of this country is too
terrified of being accused of not being
balanced to come out and state the
obvious that emotionally the president
is not at all balanced and that while
all of our lives depend on whether he
gets less crazy or more crazy apparently
it is no longer worth the risk to
American reporters to ask just how crazy
he is at this particular moment resist
peace